thank you and yes I people say oh you
did Alexa I said yes did Alexa but not
that one oh you did ways yes but not
that one and so it's it's it's a little
disappointing at times but I started and
run the Internet Archive which is a
nonprofit library to build a universal
access to all knowledge can we go and
make it so that all the published works
of humankind would be available to
anybody anywhere and the like that's the
the goal of the Internet Archive and
signed on to the Internet long long ago
to try to help make that vision come
true starting in 1980 and there's sort
of steps along the way to get get here
and the Internet Archive we started in
midnight in 1996 to try to fill in some
of some of the pieces that were missing
from this internet that we were building
I thought that the big problem was going
to be making things permanent and make
things but archiving the World Wide Web
making the Wayback Machine going and
digitizing things and putting them
online and I didn't realize that sort of
the revenge of AOL would come back with
these platforms whether the Facebook or
Twitter and the like that are really
changing this the structure of sort of
the open Internet that we imagined so
we've seen it go really quite quite
wrong actually and I think in general
there's a sort of a general feeling that
the web has betrayed us that the web as
we've came to imagine it is not what is
actually happening and it feels like a
big spyware universe and it's sort of
blocked and and sort of shuffled and
we're sort of sold as pawns as part of
advertising players networks and for me
they if there was the Snowden
revelations that really helped spawn the
Internet Archive to go and try to build
a decentralized web and then there's the
the election the last presidential
election in the United States which
independent of who you might want to
have been elected president the whole
process was a freaking disaster just a
whole how the whole thing went through
and it wasn't just internet you know
BOTS from from Russia though there
certainly there and playing a role
playing up on Twitter and Facebook and
the like but we also had election
machines being not something you could
trust the whole gerrymandering
structures there's how the primary
system is built doesn't optimize for who
everybody wants I mean we we don't have
a democracy system that sort of operates
in any way that you'd kind of imagine
how the media and the journalism was
played by basically it trolls and even
people that get elected are basically at
this point trolls they know how to play
the media game so after the election
this was you know how it all played out
was sort of a shock and and and horrible
thing I got together a set of the
executive directors of some of the Bay
Area nonprofits the high tech nonprofits
and I'm a member of this club we formed
this little group of the head of
Wikipedia the head of EF f the head of
Mozilla Public Library of Science
[Music]
Internet Archive freedom of the press
foundation and I after the election I
said it's time to come together for
dinner it's it's time to meet and we got
together for dinner and I said okay the
Internet Archive is a hundred and fifty
people I'll put my organization on the
table and say what are we for now
what happened during this election and
what should we be now we're a non-profit
we're here to do the public good please
you know help what what can we do to
help the public sphere understand what's
going on in their universe
we'd been archiving television and
trying showing some of the biases that
were ripping through the American
electorate and through the media system
we could show where the money was coming
from from the citizens united all these
things were going on we could analyze
them but we weren't taking an active
enough role what should the Internet
Archive do there was a lot of
conversation during that dinner but
there was one thing that Katherine Maher
the head of Wikipedia said that struck
me really to my core I mean it really
sort of scared me shitless um she said
truth might fracture she was worried the
truth might fracture I said okay that
sounds bad Katherine um what does that
mean
she said in Wikipedia theirs is built on
an idea that on any particular subject
they'll be a particular consensus about
what that subject is what the title is
will be reflected in the article and
they'll be pushes in shoves but it won't
fracture into wholly different views
that are built up around a subject she
said if that happens
Wikipedia breaks and if there's
something that is as close to something
we turn to as truth out there for a lot
of subjects its Wikipedia you know the
Internet Archive is about the number
three hundredth most popular website
we're pretty psyched about that but
they're number five and so being number
five you've got basically attention of
people all over the world and they're
turned away keep edia all all the time
so that's that okay Katherine that
sounds pretty bad you know how did this
happen how would this happen
and she said something that I had never
heard before she said citation wars that
behind the every web page on Wikipedia
there's battles going on of so what um
what facts what assertions are going to
be put into the article and there's
conversations and back-and-forth
especially about the contentious ones
and she said behind the scenes the way
that those Wars happen is based on the
weight of citations if you can go and
say something is true then it is true
based on some citation if it's a better
citation you win
what are better citations in Wikipedia
they bias towards things you can click
on and read if you so it it's the it's
not always that way
but if you can click on and read it it
gets more weight and so things that are
behind paywalls or never digitized in
the first place
tend to get lower bias then what you
kind of Wikipedia you want to be able to
click and see what the resource said
about this right you want to dive dive
deeper I mean it's also there's all
sorts of reasons why their their policy
is that way but a lot of things are not
available at all or they're not
available and a click button so I said
okay this is three years ago now I said
all right we'll put it all online will
digitize at all we'll go and fix all the
broken links will go and digitize all
the books we'll put all the journal
literature up will digitize the 20th
century and just make it all available
she said you could do that so we can put
our army towards it and see what we can
do Cindy Cohen who's the the executive
director of EF f the law firm for the
Public Interest she turned a little
white and she said you're gonna do what
and I said
I'm gonna just digitize it all link it
in and beyond that I'm gonna try to make
it so that there's better information
for whippy Wikipedia contributors to go
and make better articles so that they
can go and draw on the best we know and
put it into Wikipedia I'm just gonna
dedicate our organization to reinforcing
Wikipedia Cindy said I'm gonna have to
lawyer up and I said yeah I know I think
it's gonna be okay it's gonna be okay
we'll be respectful but let's let's get
there and let's get the Internet so it
actually has the best we have to offer
so when people turn to Wikipedia or
other sources but the the idea of
painting this portrait through Wikipedia
is is a strong one so we said okay what
do we do to be able to do that we wait
for the internet to to show up here on
my laptop the first thing we went out to
to do was to try to bring all of this
information and Wikipedia together as
well as we can can we make millions of
books and web pages in Wikipedia and the
web the first puzzle we did was to try
to fix the broken links so link rot so
the average life of a web page is about
a hundred days and before it's either
changed or deleted so we said let's go
and reinforce Wikipedia we started years
before monitoring every edit of
Wikipedia and anytime there was a new
URL we archived it immediately because
we knew the Wikipedia was going to need
this fixing and and help so we pushed at
it hard and we started working with the
communities at Wikipedia to go and make
this work and fortunately it all
actually did we went and wrote robots
and the community's English Wikipedia
first but then I think we're up to 20
different language editions allowed our
robots to go through and pick
and look at each link and if it changed
massively since it was awful and the
author's intent or it was broken
we went and replaced the link with a
link to the wayback machine we've
replaced 10 million links on Wikipedia
and fix them and so that there they're
now working which is kind of Awesome we
said well let's go further than that
what can we do to go and do the other
footnotes there how can we turn all of
them blue and make them work so here's a
Martin Luther King page so I'm going to
try over my cellphone Bodom connection
because it's Stanford you can't get
online if you're a guest but let's see
if this comes up yes it does okay so
here's a Martin Luther King page and
we're gonna have to pay our three
dollars to donate two hundred and
seventy five cents to Wikipedia because
it's December close that so this was the
vision of to take this article the first
footnote is in the first sentence and it
says that it is in all deliberate speed
and fortunately it's got a page number
so if this of the internet gods are
going to work I'm going to click on the
page 138 and what I'd like to do here's
our please pass by your right to the
right page just opens right to the right
page so if you wanted to read forward
and words a couple for you without any
interruption
you can check it out you can sort of see
did it say what it is you can dive in
deeper and if you want to be able to
read the book then you can borrow the
book and be able to read it this is this
control digital lending one reader at a
time it's restricted library like if we
have one physical copy then we lend a
digital copy and this
approach has been working has been
working well so it's controlled digital
lending you know free instantaneous
previews woven into Wikipedia and you
say say well that's good it's cool but
it really hasn't been done but we've
never really woven the information of
books into the web itself um you could
buy books you can go to Amazon and buy a
book or better World Books and buy a
book but or if you want to buy an e copy
of a book you get it on a Kindle but
it's not woven together there's a lot of
good information available so that's
what we went off to do oops let's see if
I can get back and as of October of last
year
we have put in a hundred and twenty
thousand citation links to forty
thousand books so we're pretty happy
about that so basically that required
getting to doing all this matching to
try to get the Wikipedia communities to
accept the robots to be able to go
through them all around on terrific but
what we really want so we've basically
gone through and tried to fix all the
broken links that we can we're
continuously scrubbing and adding more
libraries more languages and now we're
on the path towards trying to get the
books link so the question is what do
you we know is this something I had a
great experience there's a quote from my
next-door neighbor
Carmen Steele she's 15 years old I was
describing what she did and she lit up
you know what I usually don't get a rise
out of my 15 year old neighbor she said
ah I want that I said why and she said
well in my class and school I'm allowed
to go and start with Wikipedia but I
can't quote from Wikipedia I have to go
to a real book and if this happened I
could do my homework in the middle of
the night it's like scar you know you're
onto something when you're 15 year old
neighbor basically uh really says they
want to go for so how do we go and get
this to go at at scale well first was
working with Wikipedia
and Morial was was came to our big
announcement event of this and put up
this banner which I thought was just
tremendous that we're working really
well as nonprofits together that there's
the Internet Archive got the an award
from the Wikipedia community to be the
best tool best most impactful tool and
the best on the verification tools of
Wikipedia as given to us by wiki mania
so all-around good next then how do we
go and build this how do we get the rest
of the books this is a graph of the
books by decade in the Internet Archive
Collection so it's decade decade decade
decade and it's going up pretty well
until 1923 working with a lot of
libraries they were happy to go and have
these books digitized made available
this is sort of the line of copyright in
the United States and then it craters
and basically through the 20th century
we don't even get up to the 1923 level
until the end of the 20th century this
doesn't make any sense
right you know that graph goes up if you
just do the the the number of books
published but we don't have them in the
Internet Archive so you say well where
do you go for books well you know like
most people they go to Amazon and there
is a study of Amazon
and um after the internet comes back for
my phone
we'll see the same basic graph that
basically in amazon.com if you look at
books by decade there was a study it
basically also is missing the 20th
century wasn't that slide worth waiting
for
so even in Amazon basically we're
missing the 20th century so and that was
an important century right but it's not
available from the Internet Archive it's
not available from Amazon if it's
anywhere it's in our libraries so and in
also you see that even Amazon they're
not even back up to the 1923 level so
copyright is basically censoring a
century of books and keeping them from a
generation that wants to have access to
it yes no these are electronics physical
books that are available new so they're
not that not the used books so they're
there maybe use books but available new
so you can you know yes yeah they still
right you can still open them and get
them to work and yes we but we buy them
but it's but this is the study of
basically what's currently commercially
available promoted materials so control
digital lending I mentioned this before
so this is the idea of digitize and lend
this is you digitize materials and
you'll end it in the same kinds of
restrictions that you do with physical
books we've been doing this since 2011
and it's with the Boston Public Library
number other libraries that have gone
and taken books digitize them we host
them on the Internet Archive and we
distribute them one reader at a time
it sounds really clunky it is really
clunky to go and introduce scarcity but
this was a mechanism to not end up in
the same problem Google did which was
just basically getting sued and ending
up
little tiny snippets and kind of well
grinding their product their project to
be just an internal project so the
control digital lending approach we've
been working with and now scaling up
significantly so there's one physical
book for one digital book there are now
a set of law scholars that have gone and
Retin position papers and peer-reviewed
journal literature law journal
literature on how this works within the
United States it's starting to move into
Canada and there are a number of
organisations that have signed on to
support this statement there's others
that are we're weaving in their
collections and lending against their
collections so for instance Phillips
Academy Andover which is a prep school
high in prep school they have their
collection we've digitized it and then
we lend out based on their copies on
their shelves and if there's - if we
have it and they have it then we lend
out two copies and other libraries were
basically lending based on their so not
only do we have the breadth of having a
large number of different titles but you
can start to have multiple copies of
these books yes then you can't circulate
the electronic book right it's just one
there's only one allowed to be checked
out at any one time so now we're ramping
up digitization really because of the
the Wikipedia opportunity we're starting
to get large collections donated so we I
just said that the Phillips Academy
Andover we've just done their whole
collection other groups have just given
us their whole collections for instance
Trent University in Canada they were
remodeling their library they went from
five hundred thousand to two hundred and
fifty thousand books instead of going
and giving those to better rule books
they gave them to us and we've now gone
and digitized
that collection after deduplicating and
off of what it is we've already done and
that's
completely fabulous this is what it
looks like or part of it when we packed
up the collections to be digitized and
then stored forever we non-destructively
digitize books and then we store the
physical books permanently forever and
the idea is it's not very accessible if
it's in a shipping container inside a in
a box in a shipping container inside a
warehouse surprise surrounded by
nonprofits but it's preserved the
accessible copy
is-is-is online good news we also just
finished a college library a college
went out of business called Mary Grove
College in Detroit Michigan and instead
of it was very sad that they went under
but they took their whole library and
they gave it to us so it's the first
complete college library so we have a
complete prep school library and now
we're gonna have a complete college
library to be able to add into the other
millions of books that we're starting to
get this is what Trent University now
looks like online and a lot of these
books that have really never circulated
or circulated very rarely at Trent
University are now finding a new life
for people that are finding through
Google through Wikipedia and also
machine learning type things that are
going through and ripping through these
books Georgetown Law Library has been
participating in this Michelle was one
of the scholars that has opined on the
idea of control digital lending and
here's their library card catalog liquid
assets you go click on that and it says
that it's available online as well as
physically and they'll lend out one or
the other and you can go to the Internet
Archive and borrow the book for 14 days
and then it's automatically returned so
this hack this approach is working
towards bringing in copyright non rights
cleared materials to a limited number of
readers in very much in the library
tradition
this is our books scanner so now that
we're starting to get the books we want
it to be able to digitize on them more
efficiently so we have built and
operates Kanner's we've been ramping
that up here's a picture of a major
scanning Center in the Philippines that
we operate there where they're scanning
books and records and the like and it's
very efficient and they're very well
well done
we're looking for a wish list of books
so we said okay well let's prioritize
books out of all books to be the ones
that we want first and so Wikipedia list
was was one of the inputs another was
what we're on course syllabi there's a
project called the open syllabus project
that basically crawls the web looking
for syllabi and it basically rank orders
those books based on how many syllabi
they were on and so we've taken a large
hunk of those and also the commonly held
books in libraries and we have about 1.5
million on the top wish list of 4
million more broadly and then we want
all books all together so then the
question is where do you get those books
so the libraries have been really slow
about making the in copyright materials
available to the Internet Archive or
otherwise so we went for where the
libraries dispose of books and we went
back to our traditional friends have
better World Books better World Books
isn't a used bookstore that you may have
bought from even on it's integrated use
books on the bottom of Amazon or go to
better World Books calm and it is a used
bookseller that gets its books from
libraries that are weeding their
collections so when a pulse comes
through they might buy 10 copies of this
and then they only need five copies and
they give five copies to better world
books the better World Books goes and
tries to sell the ones that they can
they donate the money
the literacy programs and the libraries
and they try to keep things out of
landfill by giving them to others for
instance the Internet Archive we need it
they've been giving us tens of thousands
slow hundreds of thousands of books but
I came to them last year and said we
need millions of books to be able to to
live up to this opportunity can you give
us millions of books and it was it was a
very strange conversation with the CEO
he said well Brewster you can you have a
choice you can either buy the books from
us or you can buy the company and I
think that wasn't the conversation I
thought was gonna have um and he said
well we got ourselves in trouble with
some debt with these social capital
people that you know wanted to you know
impact investing which really I think
impact investing means the impact anyway
so they'd gotten themselves in in
trouble and they needed a new friend and
we said we really need better World
Books to survive and so um I talking
with Dustin Dustin Holland we formed a
non-profit funded it out of the
endowment of the Internet Archive and
flipped it nonprofit so better World
Books which is this unbelievably cool
bookstore with millions and millions of
books this is their facility in Indiana
is is now a non-profit or it's a
nonprofit owns all the shares of this B
Corp and it's is basically sending books
off of their robot straight to the
Internet Archive to be digitized if it's
on the wish list and if it's not then it
goes and waits um until we can get get
to it but we're still working off the
wish list as much as we possibly can so
we're starting to see the flow of you
know we have the distribution partner
Wikipedia of your dreams on the idea of
robots to go and try to match those is
not easy needs more help then there's
how do we get the books we we now have a
source of books we have a mechanism of
digitizing it and and we're we're we're
starting to run at scale but let's bring
it back down to
why I work with a woman named Wendy Hana
Mora she's japanese-american and her
grandmother was in an internment camp
um and so when she was a kid and she
heard about camps she thought it was
something quite different until she
heard the camp had barbed wire and that
her grandmother had gone through this
she made it her passion project at the
Internet Archive to basically go and try
to make sure that this knowledge of the
internment stays alive there's now
already internment deniers um there are
people that say that it wasn't that bad
it was really for their protection they
actually liked it all of this stuff is
actually happening as you you know you
sort of say yeah of course it's
happening but it's like this is really
horrible so she made it her job to sort
of just take that subject area and and
move it forward that there's this
particular camp that really oh that was
a Japanese internment camp is now being
used for children immigrants to intern
them coming across the border and just
this hmm
[Music]
which which camp Fort Sill Fort Sill so
this idea of history repeating itself is
is particularly sensitive to these
groups so let's try to remember so how
do we go and and do this how do we go
and make it so that there's still facts
around these are pictures from there and
we've been digitizing these and making
them available on the internet with some
funding from the National Park Service
there is 500 key books about the
japanese-american experience and with
the funding from the Park Service we
digitized all of these and then went
back to the Wikipedia article to make it
so that you could find these because
otherwise how are you going to find you
know yes it's great that it's online how
you go and find them so went back to
Wikipedia turns out that the Japanese
and internment article is really not
that great um it doesn't have a lot of
of the solid information in it so
they're starting to work through and and
fix it and but it's how people know
about the Japanese internment that I was
really surprised just that page gets
700,000 views a year that that is sort
of the the real stopping place that
people use as the library so let's make
it as good as we possibly can because it
matters to be able to go and make sure
that this doesn't get sort of smashed
around and manipulated as we're seeing
the rest of our information ecology and
disinformation campaigns some of it just
because they didn't have access to the
real information so they just kind of
made stuff up and we can fix that and
can we also make it so that
disinformation is is easier to do so now
there's better books that are available
for 14 days um that you can go and check
out or see a few pages for free so I
would say we have I would I saw it as a
call to action that we needed to make
the web better we needed to go we and
specifically in the Bay Area we helped
really create this and and create this
mess and it's ours to go and put forward
a possibilities and structures to fix it
that and the Internet Archive with
Wikipedia is just one example but
imagine we had these all linked what if
we could start to then go and do
automatic fact-checking
to go and say is the assertion on
Wikipedia actually backed up by that
book or journal article or can you start
to detect bias at scale can you start to
go and detect vandalism I I had I was
just two weeks ago a friend of mine said
I didn't know you were Jewish I said
I could be perfectly happy being Jewish
but I not and they said um they said oh
but your Wikipedia article says you are
and it's like really so I went to my
Wikipedia article and sure enough there
had been an edit on September 29th um
that was from an ipv6 anonymous no login
but an ipv6 address that said that I was
raised in a Jewish family um turns out
that that's now a common minor vandalism
thing that's going through they're doing
this a lot and or who's they we don't
know but this type of corruption of our
ecosystem is starting to happen and I
think that we need to spring into action
and even if we're working in different
organizations we all have to basically
pitch in and help the Internet
information ecosystem work a whole lot a
whole lot better that we can working
together complete the life cycle of
books basically if you take university
press books often they're only printed
in about 500 copies Cornell University
Press their baseline is about a hundred
and fifty copies of that book and then
it sits there forever
not being digital in many many cases
this doesn't make any sense it's some of
the best most vetted information that we
have on these particular subjects let's
get this stuff online get it pay authors
and publishers awesome please do let's
get them into libraries let's then
digitize those we've them into the World
Wide Web respectfully and then let's use
that both for end users reading people
writing to go and build better
information resources things like
Wikipedia and and journalism and the
like but then also use it for computer
determinations and build that global
brain that we promised so many years ago
can we go in and do this and we've books
and then the next step is journal
literature into the web absolutely
got the role and the responsibilities
it's not that expensive but it takes
concerted effort the five people think a
little bit outside of there oh I'm just
gonna make another crappy Android app
and make a lot of money by going in blah
blah blah blah blah let's go and build
something that we can be proud of
and let's reinforce the web frankly
before it's too late
it is ours we helped build this thing we
can help fix this thing and this is just
an example of one effort to do so thank
you very much questions
sigh hub there sigh hub library Genesis
what CD was when it was probably the
best music library ever in the world yes
what do we do about these the next real
role for the Internet Archive so is is
journal literature so the books we're
starting to really move along on if you
look at the where people go from
Wikipedia just as a right now that the
major place they go is the Wayback
Machine by a factor of three more than
every other place any other site on the
internet are on the Internet it's the
Wayback Machine and it's because we've
fixed all those broken links and the
next is books and the next is journal
literature so how do we go and get these
online we're doing a couple different
initiatives and the brian newbould who
was at MIT he's sort of inspired by
aaron sports said let's means he's not
working at the Internet Archive to go
and try to get whatever it is we can and
as straightforwardly as we can so if
there's sort of risk list to risky
areas of journal literature the most
risk lists in terms of law is open
access materials but even getting open
access materials is difficult because a
lot of publishers say you can pay us to
make it open access but then they make
it very hard to find and so we're
basically using web crawlers and
spending a lot of time and effort to try
to crawl and find as many of those and
tag them with document object
identifiers to be able to go and and
make those more easy easily found where
the next set ensures the least risky is
these those that are publicly accessible
somewhere on the web at some point maybe
it's a professor's web site and the like
and so this is working with sightseer
and the microsoft scholar people and and
others to go and try to crawl all those
we've been actively actively crawling
them the universe of journal literature
is about a hundred million articles one
hundred two hundred and twenty million
articles the we have now found 18
million of them it represents about 37%
of the Wikipedia do is so that's good
that those are clickable to be able to
go to them we have not woven them back
into Wikipedia and we also have a lot
more jernt PDFs that we're trying to
figure out what they're do is are
because it's all it's actually all
fairly challenging um and but that's a
good set of materials the next set is
microfilm um for us and I'm going from
least risky to more risky or difficult
or are harder to get to so a lot of
materials during the 20th century we're
micro films I'm going to show you
something that's kind of fun
there's
how are we doing good this is a story in
three images so during the 20th century
a lot of materials were micro filmed and
in fact all the way up until a few years
ago it was done by University micro
films and then that got bought by a
Xerox and the penny poles then ProQuest
then it was spun off into na publishing
to service and then that company went
bankrupt but this is a picture of
microfilm
it's a photographs of of pages then this
is a picture of a print masters this is
if your school wanted 1946 Time magazine
or or even 200 2010 a canister like this
would be pulled off the shelf each one
of those is a year of a periodical so
that's your year year year year year
year of a periodical and each one of
those periodicals has many issues and
each one of those issues as many
articles right that's a lot of
information on each one of those reels
it was another shot at building
universal access to all knowledge but
people don't like using microfilm I'm
not sure they ever did really like it
I'm the last person that really loved
microfilm I think but that is about 20
years of a periodical okay here's the
big reveal if you look at that corridor
do you see in the middle there's me I
I'm really tiny there and this is one
row of one floor of the vault we bought
so it is e Norma's it's 15,000 titles so
Time magazine would be one its 400,000
publication years its 500 million pages
so we are in the process of figuring out
how to digitize this we've been doing
these we have the equipment where we're
trying to get it to be efficient enough
we need to be able to find the page
numbers automatically because we want to
match against any footnote we want to
we'd really like any Wikipedia article
but also your PDF viewer in your browser
that go and see a footnote click on it
and go to the to it we're trying to also
figure out by working with some legal
folks that you see california-berkeley
to go and figure out how we can make it
available whether there's interlibrary
loan or control digital lending we don't
exactly know but how to go and get this
level out there because a lot of this
isn't even out there at all and then so
with the microfilm and beyond that
there's things like sigh hub or JSTOR
and the idea is to work with those guys
to go and make things more available so
that gives the periodicals it doesn't
get the newspapers Carl that you
mentioned but I think the periodicals
were on our path but we need help so
going and finding the articles within
these scanned documents is a bit tricky
you can use sort of sizes of fonts we
can run the OCR on it but we have to go
and find because you really want to
search based on author and title and and
and do some level of page analysis not
just using it to resolve titles
footnotes to find it but how can we go
and do more than that then can we start
to do meta science can we go and use
these collections including SIOP to go
and start to do analyses across
everything that has been authored in
particular areas you know this has been
going great in medicine because of
MEDLINE and NIH is awesome but NSF
hasn't really followed into that and
being as awesome as NIH and in terms of
going surfacing these materials there's
a collection of SCI hub that's in an
Indian University now that is being used
for large-scale science so even that is
is being done in different places but
it's not as
publicly available as maybe they'd want
to a in university but they are our
underground sites so we need to get
there there's plenty of money in this
whole general sphere it's just not being
spent very well the libraries are often
going and building a lot of these closed
systems and organizations that are
closed and we need to define a different
model around it but we can't wait for
that yes okay were you
yes Wikipedia in their particular case
because they're particularly strange
little you know things they try to find
things that are stay step back from the
controversies right they try to find
parts that are not controversial then
they link off to the alternative and but
they're really not designed for we
completely disagree fundamentally about
what this even means and that's that's
where you know you need an authority but
the wikipedia is this big experiment of
can we actually work together to build a
sense of what the world is about and so
far so good but don't take any of this
stuff for granted if we built it it can
be destroyed yes or they don't even
force that these that everything that
they're doing is should be publicly
available so there's that there there
are a bunch of things that people all
over this structure right we are the
establishment right we should just be
better establishment this is it we're
just screwing it up and we should be
doing our jobs and rethinking our jobs
and not just babbling our old biases you
know for sitting in NSF or whatever
[Music]
and just wondering about citizen
scanners citizen scanners yes there are
groups that are doing that they just
they operate in the underground that's
what basically sigh hub and library
Genesis are are people basically
scanning things that they get assigned
and then they pass it around as PDFs and
then there are some aggregators but
they're operating in a legal zone that
is really challenging and they're being
challenged and and and forced
underground and that that's not good so
we need mechanisms to go and pay people
get all for that but let's go and have
accessible versions of things in fairly
short order and it may not be completely
downloadable which would be our benefit
you know so we're even trying this sort
of this lending thing as sort of going
in between but you take library Genesis
books I you can at least make them
available to the blind and dyslexic you
can use them for data data mining type
things you can start to find out what is
popular so you start to digitize those
and make them available through lending
but we need experiments to move along
and move forward because I think we're
seeing some of the real problems of not
having the best we have to offer within
reach of those digital learners if it's
not online and says if it doesn't exist
and we have basically built barricades
that don't serve us it is betraying us a
lot of older institutions that we're not
thinking creatively enough there is
money for this it's just not being
distributed very well yes
it's it's just to go and introduce
artificial scarcity to be like a library
so you're you're basically you bought a
copy you can lend a copy
you just can't lend a copy to everyone
at once why do that is to try to make it
so that there's people don't say it's
wrong and throw things at us like
lawyers right right oh if it's not a
copyright we give it away completely
everybody can download all four million
of our books
oh yeah that's all free
that's all open oh yeah yes no this is
only for the the rights burdened books
it's a long long time ago
and so there's yes any figuring out
what's out a print is kind of
problematic
yeah the wayback machine has been useful
for that yes why it's not the most risky
the most risky is would be SCI hub yeah
I mean it's not risky as hard I mean
so we're robotize 'uncle Ekta these open
access materials and the things that are
publicly available on the web doing that
is actually really really hard work
so I guess risk ease maybe not the right
word hard um then I guess
well then SCI hub actually isn't hard
because it's fairly easily scarfed up
but it is risky yeah it's film
it is faster to do microfilm but it's a
matter of budgets and so you know here's
here's my my my plea to you alright this
is the end of the year the Internet
Archive is largely funded through
donations like Wikipedia but where they
make 100 million dollars a year at their
end of the year donation drive we will
be lucky to make 2 million our budget is
about 18 million dollars a year we could
really use help I think we are a bargain
we're more back-end and infrastructure
oriented than something like a Wikipedia
but just please contribute to your
favorite organizations and think about
it a lot especially these days the you
know e FF good organization to support
Wikipedia Internet Archive public
knowledge these are really in our sphere
but there's other things that you also
probably believe in and I think of it as
tithing
let's tithe the way that frankly we used
to do we as people at the sort of 3 or 5
percent of our gross incomes to public
service there's there are people that
really are sitting out the dot-com gold
rush to build basically building these
sorts of services and trying to make
things work where you give your product
away is challenging so that these
organizations have a different kind of
model that fit well with the internet
but they don't they're not easy to know
exactly how you raise the money to be
able to support a Wikipedia or the like
remember Wikipedia is number five of all
websites and it's running on a hundred
million dollars that's the kind of
amazing and way way to live
the Internet Archive we should also so a
plead towards contributing not you know
maybe not the Internet Archive but other
things yeah okay I love that question
there Internet Archive / donate and you
can donate Bitcoin which actually a lot
of people do which is kind of awesome
we're also two other crypto and and
please it's it's easy and
straightforward so as I understand it
the way that Sai hub and library Genesis
are distributed is they package
themselves a sets of materials into
chunks that are then distributed with
BitTorrent and so you can go and
subscribe to those BitTorrent and get
those chunks and then bring up the the
collection again on on websites or you
can just use those for scientific
research which based on the haughty
trust outcome court outcome may be okay
to go and use this for doing meta
science as is not not a lawyer
hottie trust it was Authors Guild versus
the trust which was part of the Google
Books set of lawsuits yes
yeah yes Carl Malamud it's been a real
firebrand in that area and has paid to
digitize a lot of these google has
digitized them but then they didn't open
them up which is kind of yeah so there's
there are collections there's there's
the system called pacer which is court
documents that you have to pay for to go
and get even though the public domain so
there was a program called recap that
was operated out of Princeton and as one
of the projects that Aaron Schwartz was
involved in that basically you do this
browser plugin if you go to pacer it
goes and checks the Internet Archive to
see whether we have it already if it
does it just gives it to you for free if
it doesn't if you buy it it then puts it
into the Internet Archive so we've been
running that we have millions of court
cases documents to to do that that was
the first by going in downloading a lot
of public domain materials in the Boston
Public Library Aaron Schwartz I was the
time that the FBI started following him
and went and staked out his house which
is kind of Awesome so you know there's
support your local public advocacy group
I mean there's it's it's there are big
forces against people trying to make
public access to the public domain for
instance yesterday Carl Malamud was in
front of the Supreme Court of the United
States I kid you not because he went and
digitized and made available Georgia
state law and Georgia state law Georgia
the state of Georgia claims copyright on
it so they sued him and and it's gone
through the courts for the last several
years there's been a lot of pro bono law
talent been put on that and it was
argued in front of the Supreme Court
yesterday so fingers crossed on on this
and it's public resource org another
organization
worth supporting how's our election
system doing if you ask somebody how is
the internet doing I mean is the web
certain become synonymous with
surveillance crap right are we in danger
of losing this maybe I am too far in the
weeds on that maybe it's all really rosy
out there I don't think so and I don't
think even the public perception of
what's going on on the world wide web is
is all that great and this is epicenter
I'm at Stanford University dudes I mean
come on it's within a hundred miles of
here that and it's our friends that are
making a lot of these decisions that are
going very very wrong and we have to go
and do something about it and you know
you'll be you know see this video of
this lecture you go that was kind of
interesting what's for dinner it's like
no it's not good enough um there's it's
our fault and we need this this stuff is
our opportunity it was what we've done
for the world it's what a lot of us
dinner a careers are in this tech area
um let's not foul it up now let's not
make it so that you know our kids are
gang kids go and say so how did you
screw it up so bad you know that's the
sort of thing I'm starting to get from
some of the crypto guys it's like how
did you just blow the Internet so badly
and how can we learn to not repeat your
mistakes awesome right I mean this is
not what your legacy you want to do so
let's fix it the technology the law and
policy structures the institutions they
are fixable but they require us to work
hard to do it that that is what it takes
to be able to keep a structure that is
evolving it is a new and different
structure it's had its wins
um I think Wikipedia is just a miracle I
think Google Maps is a miracle good
every time I use Google Docs it's
completely fantastic it's great but why
don't we go
fix the rest of the pieces that need our
help
and when these are help and we ran an
unbelievably good place to do it it is
up to us
well digitize it great so now I'm sorry
that at this point it would be great
would and and as well we'll take any
donations of media yes
it's hard to play a play within the sum
of the forces of just commercial
companies it's just really irresistible
as well as as government's and we just
have to not do some of these things we
when I was growing up there's there's
the nuclear threat I mean somebody could
have hit that button and they haven't
yet it came close a number of times but
we haven't actually had a major nuclear
weapon go off on top of people since we
did it so let's let's do our parts let's
go and make sure that we're building as
good an environment as we can so that we
can be free to be a little stupid that
we can look things up and not feel like
you're you're being watched all the time
for what it is you're you're reading
that we can pay for good things that are
being done that actually help whether
it's authorship or technologies that you
actually want to support it's it's not
gonna be easy it's not gonna be easy a
lot of the technologies make
authoritarian structures by companies
and governments really default easy and
it'll be convenient it'll be convenient
I mean I'm really a fan of the crypto
currencies as a alternative to an ally
pay Ally pay in China's how are you
going buy almost anything you know the
street stuff people don't carry cash in
a large part of China anymore because
it's so convenient to use Ali pay but
it's all going into centralized
databases can we have the equivalent of
cash yes we can but we actually have to
have to do it and there are forces that
are really really really against it
so do we have the right systems yet no
do we have some of the paths through yes
if we put ourselves in the position to
go and make enforce the changes and
build the technologies that are better
open how do we go and show the value of
openness so we don't end up with
little silos of social media systems you
have to log into and how many different
messaging systems do you have to listen
to oh you're a student here how many
different social media messaging systems
do you and any particular day do you get
messages from it's not just email
anymore maybe five and they're all
completely siloed in these completely
weird ways and they have different
policies around them how do we go and
build an open system that interoperates
that works that protects the values that
builds our values into the code itself
Lessig sent code is law and therefore
our code should reflect our values and
right now it doesn't the code that we're
running is often somebody else's values
being put on us or it's so generic like
the World Wide Web so we didn't bake the
first amendment into the code itself we
didn't make privacy into it we didn't
make it so you could actually go and
sell things on the world wide web very
easily you you just can't do it you have
to go and put your stuff on an Amazon or
an iTunes or something like that it
doesn't make any sense
we've centralized so key parts that has
put an inhibitor on the experiments and
the growth that we could be seeing yes
there are there are other ways than just
making companies but let's build
technologies that people want to use and
you know this are we aren't we in the
greatest place to try to be able to do
this I'm aware and right now the
threshold for getting new services out
there is actually relatively low again
so growing up the idea of making a
product and trying to get it distributed
was super hard you had to go and get it
built yeah the distributor then you had
to try to get it into retailers it had
to be on shelves it was a very difficult
thing now you can build websites that go
and get out there are apps that are that
it can get out there and catch on if
they're done well let's go and build
good ones and I'm just dedicated to the
pieces that I'm I'm throwing my cells at
but part of it that you're gonna throw
yourself at and I think with that I
think I should shut down I'm still
around but let's call the the session
done thank you
[Applause]